good to see you again I saw you very
recently a very nice event Bat Mitzvah
yes for your eldest daughter she had a
bat mitzvah and and I went and you would
dress very nice that day I supposed to
dress up before he stepped it up for
temple this is how you were dressed you
were I always say he dresses like he has
the flu yeah
I was doing suits don't fit me right I
don't know why the itchy and they don't
I don't know how to work you're a child
is why each other yeah but I was doing a
Saturday Night Live you know how you do
the the pictures in the beginning yeah
they did I had a suit on and I said hey
this suit feels pretty but mister was
the next week and I said may I yeah keep
this police and they said yes so wait
you took the suit yes we did you for two
hoster alive and you stole it for the
button it's funny it was really fun
because I got to see I got to see Chris
Rock David Spade wearing yarmulkes oh
yeah you had you had a lot of people at
the bottom it's fun it was fun to see
them and then there was a party
beautiful party crazy big party
afterwards and I got I sat next to David
Spade's mother yeah yeah yeah yeah and I
heard she was nervous talking to Destin
huh she was she saw Dustin Hoffman
sitting on the other side of it over in
a corner and she was like that's Dustin
Hoffman I think that's right mrs. BAE
I'm gonna go talk to him and I'm gonna
tell him my two favorite movies are
Tootsie and the movie big and I said
okay he's only in Tootsie dr. Hoffman
and she went yeah but those are my two
favorite movies
and I said yeah just don't mention the
second one just to celebrity don't list
one and then and then the other one
you're not in but I think I saw him
listening and be happy and I son go whoo
ha ha ha I'm kidding kidding me like
he's a big hands man